let's continue with the gmat problem so
we are on
problem 16 on page 279
problem 16. is x greater than 1.8
is x greater than 1.8 that's all they're
asking us and statement 1 says
x is greater than 1.7 well that doesn't
help us because i don't know x could be
1.71 in which case this wouldn't be true
or x could be
a million in which case this is true so
this isn't really that helpful
immediately see that
statement number two says that x is
greater than 1.9 well if you're greater
than 1.9 you're definitely greater than
1.8 so this is all we need statement
number two so b
problem 17
problem 17. if n is an integer is n plus
1 odd
n plus 1
odd
well if n plus 1 is odd
that's the same thing as asking is n
even
and i haven't looked at the statements
yet but that's just something your brain
might automatically connect and let's
see what do they tell us statement 1
tells us that
n plus 2
is even
well if n plus 2 is even then n is
definitely even
then n is even
if you don't believe me
think about
the number four four is even and four
plus two is six which is still even
right because if you add one you're
going to go from even to odd you add two
you go back to even right so this is all
we need if n plus two is even then we
know that n is even and that n plus 1 is
odd and you could try it out with
numbers if you don't believe me
2 what is statement 2 where did that
number oh n minus 1 is odd well this is
the same thing n minus 1 is odd
once again this tells us that
that n has to be an even number if you
subtract one from it and you get an odd
number it has to be even if you say that
n is four
four minus one is three and try it for
any even number and you know how i think
it's i don't to over explain what's a
fairly simple problem so anyway the
answer is that either of them alone are
sufficient d and try it out with numbers
if you don't believe me
problem 18
problem 18.
is x between 1 and 2 is essentially what
they're saying and it can't be one or
two because these aren't
equal signs they're just less than signs
okay so that's what they're asking
statement one tells us that x is
essentially greater than zero they were
a little different they said zero is
less than x so x is greater than zero
that doesn't help us x could still be
point one it could still be one half so
that doesn't tell us where it is in this
range
and then the next and it could it could
also be a hundred in which case it's out
of this range
statement two tells us that x is less
than three
x is less than three so this alone
doesn't help us x could still be 2.1 or
x could still be minus a million this
doesn't help us and even if we took them
together that would just tell us that 0
is less than x which is less than 3
which is a superset of this right if we
know that x is in this range it doesn't
tell us that x is definitely in this
range for example if we know this is
true x could still be equal to one half
but one f isn't in this range
x could be equal to
1.5 which is in the range or x could be
equal to 2.5
which isn't in the range so both of
these even taken together are not
sufficient so the answer is e
problem 19
these are going fast maybe too fast
let me know if i'm going through too
fast okay water is pumped into a
partially filled tank at a constant rate
through an inlet pipe at the same time
water is pumped out of the tank at a
constant rate through an outlet pipe
okay so
essentially we have a tank
some water is let me there's a pipe here
so water is going in at you know x we
could say i don't know meters cubed per
second or meters the units shouldn't
matter and it's getting pumped out at y
meters cubed per second
at what rate in gallons per minute okay
so these aren't meters per second these
are gallons per minute
and these are gallons per minute
at what rate in gallons per minute is
the amount
of water in the tank increasing
so in order for the water to be
increasing more has to be coming in than
going out and the rate of it is going to
be the difference so essentially they
just want to know what x minus y
gallons per minute are
if x is less than y
and we get a negative number here then
actually we have more coming out than
going in and so the water isn't
increasing
so anyway they tell us that one
the amount of water initially in the
tank is 200 gallons that's useless
why is that useless because that just
tells us how much water is in the tank
it doesn't tell us anything about the
rates going in or out so this is that's
useless
two
water is pumped into the tank at a rate
of 10 gallons per minute so x is equal
to 10 gallons per minute right that's
the rate you're pumping into it
and out of the tank at a rate of 10
gallons every two and a half minutes
so y is equal to
10 gallons
per
2.5 minutes
which is equal to what
that's
four
gallons per minute
so that second statement was a little
bit
with that second part of
statement two is a little bit shady but
you get a y it's four gallons per minute
and so you actually don't have to figure
it out but if you wanted to you could
say that the rate at which water is
increasing is
the rate which is coming in at 10 minus
3 is going out
so it's 6 gallons per minute is actually
the answer to the question but all you
have to know is that you just needed
statement 2
which gave us this information to figure
it out and statement 1 was useless so
that's b statement 2 alone
is sufficient
let's do another one
okay
so we have problem number 20.
problem number 20. is x negative
x negative
negative number okay the first statement
they tell us that 9x
is greater than
10x
so this is this is this is an
interesting situation so let's let's
let's try to solve this equation let's
subtract 10x from both sides of this
equation
and if you're adding or subtracting on
both sides of an equation inequality the
inequality stays the same so let's
subtract 10x from both sides of this
so you get 9x
minus 10x
is greater than 10x minus 10x
and then you get minus x
is greater than
zero
or you could multiply both sides by
negative one you get x
and when you multiply or divide by a
negative number with an inequality you
switch the inequality x is less than
zero so we know that x is definitely
negative you the other way you could
have done you subtracted 9x from both
sides and you've gotten 0
is greater than x which is a faster way
of doing it but either way statement 1
lets us know that x is definitely
negative
let's see what statement two does for us
statement two
x plus three is positive
x plus three
is positive
well i mean x could be a hundred
if x is a hundred then 103 is definitely
positive or x could be negative one
right because negative one plus three is
positive two so this doesn't tell us any
information about whether x is negative
so this is useless so the answer is a
statement one alone is sufficient
statement two alone is useless
see how much time do i have oh i'm doing
well on time
it's clear
i'm on problem 21.
does 2m minus 3n
2m minus 3n
equal
equals 0. and then the first
and let's just think about this they're
also asking that's the same thing as
asking does 2m equal 3n if you just
add 3n to both sides these are
equivalent questions so if you can
answer one you can answer the other
so statement 1
statement 1 says
m does not equal
zero
well that seems fairly useless to me i
mean
m does not equal zero so m is is still
you know i could pick a random n not
equal to zero and you i'd get different
you know depending on what n is this may
or may not be true
so so far that seems kind of useless for
me but maybe it's useful in conjunction
with two
the next thing they say six m is equal
to nine n
6m oh this one's interesting is equal to
n
so what does this tell us
so
6m is equal to 9n
so if we do if we let's say let's divide
both sides by
let's divide both sides by 3 we get 2m
is equal to 3
n and then we can subtract 3n from both
sides and you get 2m
minus 3n is equal to zero so statement
two i mean you essentially just do a
little bit of algebra and you get what
we're trying to prove so statement true
two is good
statement one do we need it at all well
no because you know i mean that is kind
of one solution that if m and n are both
equal to zero that this thing is is true
but it doesn't it doesn't really do as
much in the way of anything else and we
don't need it for to come up with this
so the answer is b statement two alone
is
sufficient oh i'm already past the 10
minutes so that's it i'll do 22 in the
next video see you soon